battles in New Paltz New York target a
pizza parlor for the crime of painting
an American flag mural Lauren spoke
earlier with LaBella pizza bistro owner
maria la santé and Joey Garcia a veteran
who organized a parade to support the
flag let's watch mural painted I guess
it was kind of an old wall you wanted to
spruce it up you had some problems I
understand with protesters and for
people who don't know that where this is
this is in New Paltz New Yorkers about
80 miles north of New York City and it's
a fourteen thousand twelve thousand
people a town small town but what were
the protesters beef what was their beef
about the flag well they they didn't
want a flag they they thought that it
meant a political position and they were
opposed
well what political position is the flag
other than this is the United States of
America did you did you engage in any
conversations with them
no I didn't I really didn't interact
with them at all I just observed well
how did that when were they standing
outside Maria were they coming in and
and in expressing themselves verbally to
you saying I'm not gonna ever order one
of your pizzas or grinders or what I did
have I did have a few people come in and
say they couldn't support my store any
longer because they felt that I took a
political position so that they couldn't
spend their money wait a second why is
that wait is it okay these college kids
because I know you got a college you got
State University of New Paltz right and
in town were they college kids no in
particular that was not a college kid
that that came in and told me that oh
that's a relief
okay so that happened and then
fast-forward to the paint splattered all
over the mural that people across the
country are wondering why are we focused
on this small town of New York and this
one mural and this one defacement of the
mural and I'm we're focusing on it
because it's our flag and it represents
a lot Joey you're a veteran
you saw that this had happened in your
hometown you decided to do what and why
so when I saw the pushback she was
getting for her putting an American flag
mural up I personally had a problem with
that so I had the idea why don't we have
an event where we all just come together
in support of the flag and cipro the
mural and show our support and I wasn't
sure how it was gonna go what kind of
turnout we'd get we end up having like
four or five hundred people came out it
was amazing we all had our flags we
showed our support it was a great
positive peaceful day and Joey did you
have a chance to speak to any of these
these brave protesters who were against
this mural did you ever engage in any
meaningful dialog with any of them
I tried there's not much meaningful
dialog to be had with most of them the
day of the event we had some of them
show up yeah I try to talk to them you
know try to you know explain hey you
guys have the right to be out here so do
we let's keep the peaceful they really
didn't want to hear any of that I was
labeled many different names by people
you know some of these protesters some
people in the community for putting this
walk together but it was just about
supporting our flag our military and our
law enforcement Joey doesn't seem like
these protests are just from the way
they appear there it's an aggressive I
don't even know if it's a protest it's
an aggressive intimidation campaign
they're trying to intimidate Moorea to
put something else up there to frighten
her that's why they have like the you
know the black flags it looks more like
Isis than you know any type of peaceful
protest that I was used to seeing
growing up so their goal is to do what
really to a tab more dialogue or to shut
it down to shut it down they disagree
with it so they'd rather it just go away
and not be there and they didn't want us
to be out there that day like I said we
have four or five hundred of us there
was like 30 of them that's great and we
just did our thing you know our chance
for us a there chance you can't say on
TV lovely yeah unity and diversity day
by the way is something that has been
celebrated in New Paltz New York unity
in diversity day how about a little
unity behind our nation and the idea of
liberty and freedom sorry all right guys
thank you so much for joining us tonight
we really really appreciate it and thank
you Joey for supporting Maria and I'm
glad you raised all the money to do the
new mural for the wall I'll have to
check it out if I come up there all
right guys thanks so much